chào các bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn cách định dạng
bux và định dạng numbering trong đoạn
văn thì như chúng ta quan sát bên này là
bên trái là một cái văn bản được định
dạng numbering tức là đánh số và việc
đánh số này nó theo nhiều cái mức à Một
là mã trong một là mã có một nhỏ hai nh
hoặc là trong một nhỏ nó có a b c Vân
Vân bây giờ chúng ta sẽ thực hiện như
sau Thứ nhất là chúng ta sẽ
chọn chọn dòng hoa
cúc sau đó chúng ta Nhấn và giữ Ctrl
chúng ta lần lượt chọn các cái dòng mà
sẽ đánh
số lưu ý là Nhấn và giữ control nha Rồi
Và nếu mà chúng ta muốn cuộn màn hình
xuống thì chúng ta nhả control ra chúng
ta cuộn màn hình sau đó tiếp tục Nhấn và
giữ Ctrl để chọn
tiếp Nhấn vào dữ Ctrl chọn biếp nha Khi
nào Cuộn màn hình thì chúng ta sẽ nhả
Ctrl ra nha Rồi Như vậy là chúng ta chọn
xong các cái tiêu đề Bây giờ chúng ta
bắt đầu đánh
số thì chúng ta sẽ vào thẻ home
trong thẻ home mà chúng ta sẽ chọn đến
cái lệnh này đó là
numbering chúng ta nhắc chuột vào chúng
ta chọn Một là mã hai là mã Ba La Mã
à thì chúng ta quan sát nó nó Sẽ định số
bắt đầu từ 1 là m trở xuống
này
đấy Đến 15
này tiếp tục bây giờ là k phần màu xanh
là chúng ta sẽ định dạng là một nhỏ thì
chúng ta sẽ chọn màu xanh nà nhấn giữ
contol này chọn phần Kim Cúc Kim và cúc
đại đóa chúng ta chuyển sang nó một nhỏ
thì chúng ta sẽ thứ nhất là chọn cái
lệnh này đó là increas ident à tức là
chúng ta tăng cái lề lên Tức là nói cách
khác là dịch sang phải nhấp
đấy và đánh số của nó bây giờ chúng ta
muốn Nó không phải là ab mà nó là 1 2
thì chúng ta sẽ vào numbering này chúng
ta chọn 1
2 được chưa 1 nhỏ 2 nh này nhấp đây và
tương tự như vậy MC
pháp Việt Nam chúng ta Nhấn và giữ Ctrl
để chọn chúng ta cũng dịch chuyển qua
bên bên phải Và cũng chọn là đánh số 1
2 và tương tự như vậy l đen rô và l kiếm
chúng ta cũng dịch phải tức là tăng lề
lên đó các bạn và chọn đánh số là 1 nh 2
đây đó là mức thứ hai mức Ba là màu cam
màu cam này á thì chúng ta sẽ đánh số là
a b c chúng ta quét chọn các dòng màu
cam Nếu không liên tiếp nhau thì chúng
ta nhấn vào giữ Ctrl và chúng ta sẽ tăng
lề lần thứ nhất nó cùng mức với là màu
xanh tức là level 2 pháp Việt Nam bây
giờ chúng ta thấy rằng là A B nó nằm
trong mục 1 nh thì chúng ta tăng thêm
một mức nữa hay nói cách khác là tăng
cái cái lề lên một lần nữa nhắp một lần
nha nhắp đây và chúng ta muốn định dạng
này là a b c thì chúng ta lại vào
numbering và chúng ta lại chọn là a b c
đây và tiếp tục như thế mục hồng đơn
hồng kép này cũng vậy quét
chọn tăng lệ lên nhấp một lần hai lần và
sau đó đổi số nhấp vào numbering chọn A
A B và chúng ta được cái tài liệu giống
như như như yêu cầu được nha Bây giờ
ngoài cái việc mà đánh số này ra thì
chúng ta còn có một cái thao tác nữa là
chúng ta không đánh số mà chúng ta điền
các cái biểu tượng hay người ta gọi là
bolix thì một cách khác Này bây giờ mình
sẽ xóa các một một một là mã một nhỏ rồi
a b nha thì chúng ta cứ chọn lệnh und
trên màn hình ấy đây chúng ta cứ chọn
und này cho nó trở về như cũ có nhiều
cách để làm Tuy nhiên là mình chọn und
rồi bây giờ chúng ta
sẽ đánh số mà chúng ta sẽ không định số
là number nữa mà chúng ta sẽ định số là
poli thì chúng ta sẽ nhập vào mụ Poli
đây nhấp
đây và bây giờ chúng ta muốn đổi cái dấu
này không dùng hình tròn nữa mà chúng ta
sẽ dùng một cái hình khác thì nhấp vào
nút đổ xuống ở phần B và chúng ta chọn
ví dụ chúng ta chọn biểu tượng này đấy
rồi bây giờ tiếp tục à Cúc Kim Cúc đại
đóa hay là Pháp Việt Nam thì nó Thục vào
thì chúng ta sẽ chọn Cúc Kim nhấn giữ
Ctrl chọn Cúc đầy đóa Tiếp tục giữ Ctrl
Như vậy chọn pháp chọn tiếp Việt Nam và
cuộn mừng hình xuống thì nhả control ra
nhả C control của màn hình Nha và tiếp
tục nhấn giữ Ctrl chọn Lan dentro và lan
kiếm và chúng ta sẽ thực hiện tiếp thao
tác là tăng lệ nhấp một
lần và đổi biểu tượng khác thì chọn
numbering à bic ở đây và chúng ta chọn
biểu tượng Ví dụ như hình à
à hình vuông đấy nhắp đy và tiếp tục là
trong một pháp này các cái mục màu đỏ
màu trắng màu nhung và màu vàng này là
nó lại thuộc cái phần của Pháp Tức là nó
level 3 thì chúng ta
chọn và chúng ta tăng lề hay nói cách
khác là chuyển qua qua level 3 và chúng
ta nhớ chúng ta nhấp hai lần nha đấy và
chúng ta đổi biểu tượng thì nhấp vào
bolic này và chúng ta chuyển sang biểu
tượng này ví dụ đây Đấy Và tiếp tục hòng
đơn hòng kép chúng ta cũng thao tác
tương tự chọn hai dòng
chọn tăng Lê nhấp hai lần vì nó thuộc
level
3 và đổi b là chúng ta sẽ nhấp vào biểu
tượng B và chọn và này và kết thúc chúng
ta có được là cái văn bản được dạng buic
hoặc là numbering bên trái là numbering
bên phải là là
bing cái việc định dạng đến đây kết thúc
Xin chào các bạn